I'm not being accepted it's like my
whole driver like I just need to stop
trying to compete with each other
okay leak up and gain the power I'm not
the artist to just like wrap it in front
of a mic or a DJ behind me and just like
like try to bore you in my songs
what's that believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
and I want to see that great thing that
you have inside of you come out so you
can help change the world so to help you
in your journey today we're gonna learn
from rapper and record producer Travis
Scott and my take on his top ten rules
for success rule number eight is my
personal favorite and I'd love to know
which one you guys liked the best and as
always guys as you're watching if you
hear something that really resonates
with you please leave it down the
comments below and put quotes around it
so other people can be inspired and when
you write it down it's much more likely
to stick with yourself as well enjoy
[Music]
if you ever felt like there were times
where you wanted to quit all that music
wasn't that necessarily for you like you
didn't have faith in what you were doing
yeah or not that's good no no because uh
quitting isn't never an option but have
there been times where you've maybe felt
like you talked about being
misunderstood before have there been
times where you've made me felt like
people weren't understanding it and then
that frustration leads you to maybe not
want to continue on that path they give
me they give me going mm-hmm
that type of [ __ ] right there I'm not
being accepted it's like my my whole
driver like people enough with me and I
just want to prove a point that I'm not
as bad as I just want to know what you
go with you know and that's always
helpful information
um and I get that advice to everybody
like if someone if you feel like
quitting is the thing just childhood
quitting too like that extra pump second
wind
jay-z told me man he's like man he has a
power you know artists need to stop
trying to compete with each other okay
link up and gain the power man he told
me something that changed my life said
we can all obtain money right but
gaining the power some whole another
level how did he money
he said money is something that you can
get off the streets you could get from
corporations power is something that you
know want you taking he was saying like
oh you can give it away
for you only you can lose it he gave it
the perfect example he was like I can
stand right here and nobody can move me
if I don't want to do this no one can
telling me I can if I don't want had to
do if I went out the door I could do I
ain't got you that's true
you know I'm jay-z I hold the power
Kanye West holds the power Rihanna she
hold the power he's like if we just
build a chain instead of just trying to
compete if you had to compare yourself
if you could compare yourself to anybody
who would you compare yourself to or
would you say the sound that you kind of
follow or that you listen to listen to
like man like berserk or like MGMT type
of music
you know comparison I really I say back
in the day I used to like compare myself
to like a like some like it in my a or
like a cake cut Italian but now it's
kind of like I took I like created my
own sound and like wave and you know
cult following so I got you know I
really compared myself to anybody now
what did you start though what did it
all start for you I'm you know from
Houston Texas so you know um most city
Texas like to be like a little bit more
exact you know kind of just started
there and like um you know whether it's
like me and my DJ chase like you know we
doing house parties or like we doin like
random stuff in the city of like
whatever we doing in the city you know
to like keep poppin yeah you know my
whole thing was always creating a vibe
we're like curating alike a bar from my
culture for like my kids like me so
always wanted to put people in
environment you know with venues and
like sometimes when you try to go into
someone's establishment yeah you know it
kind of like oh it's always a conflict
because you want to rage and then they
want to like confine you to this like
box and yeah so like that was always my
thing so like it we're gonna take over
this person's house and used a backyard
uh-huh you know chase brindis KRKs
I'm gonna bring my home theater system
why we gonna just rock this so it was
kind of like that you know in most city
and then you know kind of like branched
out to Houston a little bit but then you
know just growing up in Houston Texas
alone it just doesn't have like a real
industry yeah I'm not saying it like I'm
an industry person but it's just like to
get like an outlet you know um the radio
is kind of like one sided you know the
scene is kind of one-sided too so like I
do I really leave to break the barrier
to try to like give more kids like me
you know a sonic like a sonic hearing
I'm not the artist to just like rap in
front of a mic or a DJ behind me and
just like like try to bore you with my
songs like that's not what I'm here for
I'm here to put on a show like I don't
make music to just like what it for DJ
to be behind me with this weak little
like tar Matt what is like DJ face on it
like I'm not about that you know we
create this music man with like light
shows man the people is like an
experience like those sounds like are
supposed to like control the atmosphere
aka the lights to smoke the strobes all
that I know this is some craziness but
the relations don't you jay-z said on I
knew how one was sign-in ish it's just
all cool but if you can do it by
yourself
oh my god doing by yourself so much is
way Hillier and self self teen she's
like Bailey's faster home studios is the
most of all time dude trust me I'm doing
albums in my crib yeah like just like
you can do your album in your crib do my
own micro you don't need all that crazy
man just go crazy know how to mix and
then gonna do SoundCloud and like you
can get your music on fast YouTube let's
go
I created all the joints from like
scratch like no we did no beats over
email I didn't like nobody's over email
that I worked worked hands-on that's
awesome man you know um you know and
people think like sometimes like I'd be
like you using like other producers and
uh but it's just like when I'm like
working on music we like just collabo
ideas like somebody might have a beat
you know I feel like we need to like
change it just so I can like fit no I'm
not like the regular artists you know
I'm not here to make the hit I'm just
here to make the song that applies to me
writes to the people that like Phil you
know how I feel when did the
relationship with Kanye how did that
happen um you know my manager Anthony
kill offer he's been like mixing and
producing for him for like mad long time
you know when Kanye like first started
like a regular planet where ever use
that mm-hmm and so on you know you know
I was always I'm a fan of the music I'm
a fan of the credits and I'm a fan of
people that like actually do stuff so
you know and actually create so like you
know when I was looking at the credits
on yeah I'm like man you know like Mike
Dean
keelhaul for these guys are like on here
all the time mm-hmm so always hit up my
team and I you just talked anything all
at a time and you know
saying like yo man but you know used to
like give me up you know so I used to I
used to hit kill offer on the email like
yo man you know I got these beats I got
these songs and I'm a rapper I make
beats you know so he stay me back here
near la la la so um I took like a army
hit me one day this is like doing watch
the throne area right he was like yo
King come meet me in LA and I lived in
Houston
I was like yeah like he thought I lived
in LA so I bought this ticket I met him
like right across the street from Mbita
music that record shop yeah it was like
a 15-minute meeting and I was like I
brought my laptop had all this check
here straight from the airport to the
meeting because it mean wasn't like
10:30 and like I was like we bout to go
to the studio he was like no I gotta go
on the washer to her so like so I went
back home and like you know um later on
when I start to put out my first video
and she you know he kind of like I was
working at Atlantic studio with my Karen
oh my god man and if he like came back
and watched his throne to her he was at
this coffee shop around the corner he
was like he called me like yo where you
at I was like I'm in Atlanta Gregg I
mean it's like studio man like I was
like oh this is like trap low-key and so
um you know he was like come meet me at
this coffee shop saw left and he was
like yo he was like man I wanted to man
like I want to manage you but like we
both was trying I was always trying to
accent to manage me he was trying to ask
me so we both kind of said at the same
time and I was like yes and so he came
back with me to the studio and I made
this one beat I had this one beat on my
lap on my big computer he was like yo
just crazy
he like took it with him he's like all
right he was gonna go meet Kanye the
next day so um around this time people
were trying to sign me but I didn't know
what I wanted to do like but people
wanted my publishing before like you
know I'm saying they wanted to sign me a
record deal they wanted both at the same
time I was like that smart because
that's not you gonna make your bread and
butter it's so um and so like the next
like three days later I was at this
hotel I was about to sign at Warner
Brothers like all this um
Calle K awful Karma's like yo man Kanye
did that be
he was like crazy cuz he had a song that
was already used in that same sample
uh-huh somehow I like made the beat I
had to beat beat was it was a song that
he's never came out I want to talk about
okay but you know is this song I think
I'm talking about but yes so I flew out
to New York that night that same day and
like we kicked it no we didn't kick I am
attending for the first week man yeah
and you were in New York and so this is
all like and this is around time limit
so like I was around Kanye and there met
him I was at the studio around the
corner from jungle city so I went to
Atlanta and you know that's something
like t I want to sign me so I ended up
like we ended up doing a deal with ti
and there's like the same kind of time
as like the Kanye sh it wasn't like all
the way finalized but it was like almost
done ish so Kanye brought me back to New
York cuz like I like was like working on
Murray seems like some of the shell I
did was like dope machine so I came back
to New York and um my you know we did
more music and that's when we hadn't
meet and finally any like two days later
then I played him like my original album
out Pharaoh before the album I put out
yeah he was like oh man this is like the
craziest man he's like from there we
click and then that's when I was like
scouring the cruel summer movie yeah and
then like I ended up be like he put me
on album and I did a couple of joints an
album and I was in Hawaii and then meet
him just built the relationship you know
I'm saying and it was like from Niro he
just became like a big brother to me man
like for real like I've one of my
biggest mentors man like it's crazy like
the relationship I didn't think it's
like kind of like like a dad low key
yeah I kinda like call them or like
anything usually sometimes we won't even
talk about music on a time it just be
just about life I guess because it's
like a long history of like you know
they could like be culture whatever
people using different substances to
enhance that creativity I think that's a
myth I think there's like weak people
like need all that wish just to like you
know like tap consider brain line I
think knowledge is power drugs is just
like you know a mental cooldown it just
put me at ease
I don't tap into drugs to like say
what's on my mind
I can do that sober I am a drug sober
you know sad
I'm the most mental I'm the most highest
Potro sober ever since I was six I
wanted to be a wrestler the Hardy Boys
is an amazing xpac was like my idol so
performance is always wanted to make it
feel like it was the WWF person you know
ragin and you know having fun and
expressing good feelings is something up
I plan on just like doing and spreading
across the globe I just need air and a
mic yeah I don't need a I need a stage
no we just need something to stand on it
can be somebody eyes need a platform you
don't you don't like these you don't
like people understand you know whether
you're black white brown green purple
yellow blue
you don't want you to stand it around
like this is a nose stands though we
were Travis or if you're raging of a
save you not with me okay I feel like
delete the rattle okay just for this
night you can get it back in the morning
because I love it over but tonight
you're spinning tonight wherever you if
you need to start bringing back camping
you know when people go out there is no
going home and it's like we're gonna
spend the night in the in gonna party
all the way to the singles all right you
put yourself on in your pocket because
there's no snap you can get a lot you
one picture get I'll give you one pigs
you need one memory cuz at the end I you
should be throwing up
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Kojo minta asked
me to if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you would like me to profile next
check out the link in the description
and go and cast your vote I'd also love
to know what did you learn from this
video that had the biggest impact on you
what lesson you're going to take and
immediately apply it somehow in your
life or in your business leave it in the
comments below I'm really curious to
find out I also want to give a quick
shout to to rush our legs rush ah thank
you so much for picking up a cup of my
book your one word taking that picture
posting the Instagram as well
I really really appreciate the support
and I hope you enjoyed the read thank
you guys again for watching I believe in
you hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you soon
[Applause]
and then through that Kenneth HIV joke
the top
taught me how to see
the side
take a sieve to decide every way but
knowing
you ain't allowed so that you like to
change away
when you give you the one one soon ones
ones long media the most important work
ever if you had to think of one word
that's most important to you or that
sums you Apple so it would be too like a
little beacon pay believe nation if you
want to know what the most important one
word is for Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk
Oprah Winfrey will.i.am and Howard
Schultz I have a very special secret
video for you check the description for
details
[Music]